kara wrote to me kara said David lots of
people say that even though they miss
youth generally that their lives are
better as adults you have agency you
have more control over your life etc but
do you miss being a kid and what do you
miss about it
I agree generally that you know when you
are an adult you can make decisions
about your life that are really
liberating and it's hard to even really
imagine going back to being a kid and
not being able to make decisions for
yourself so there is no doubt that being
able to direct one's life as an adult is
a really great and powerful thing at the
same time with direction with self
direction comes responsibility and I
totally understand the sort of
romanticized view of I was a kid summer
went on forever it was three months long
I didn't have to figure stuff out
parents figured stuff out for me I get
that and when you look back at your
childhood memories a lot of the time
you're thinking of the best moments
right and when that really goes to the
fact that nostalgia is it we are view
looking back on things where it wasn't
as good as it was at the time at the
time you also don't get the ways in
which things will not remain that way
later and I think that if you were able
to relive youth knowing those things
like for example the older you get the
more difficult it is to establish new
significant friendships right because
people you know the people I'm most in
touch with are people that became my
friends between ages 14 and 26 probably
and the number of close friends that
I've made in the last four years is
disproportionately small compared to the
number of close friends that I have from
when I was younger type of thing the
ease of making friends when you were
younger it's something that you may not
realize until you see how things are
different in the sort of post college
era that sort of one thing certainly I
think the idea of being able to put time
into hobbies you don't call them caught
hobbies when you're a kid it's just what
you do and as an adult you sort of have
to carve out time for these things in
many cases yeah playing with others and
socializing that's what's a belfs
friendships and a lot of the times
when we're in a sort of work environment
you get older right can't really do that
stuff anymore
yep and I think you know the other
aspect would be for me it was when
traveling to see family right when I
would go back to Argentina to see family
it was just great in every way right I
my parents figure out what what's the
trip what are the details what are we
doing and I just show up there and I get
to spend two three or sometimes four
weeks seeing my grandparents and my
cousins and all these different people
and then you go back and you come home
and although it was difficult to leave
my family it was much different than
having been the parent who made the
decision to say our immediate family is
going to separate here and we're going
to go somewhere else and while for me it
was always sort of sad to be leaving my
cousins and my friends now my adult
trips make me realize sort of the
magnitude and this makes me think a lot
about the immigration situation that we
have in this country the magnitude of
deciding to leave your country and going
elsewhere and coming back and everything
that's attached to it that is major
adult stuff and I'm sure it is draining
another thing too is I remember holidays
back in the day being the best things
because you were at the center of
attention right at this point you have
to deal with adults and socialize and
it's really not the best and you're
crazy conservative uncle who is the sort
of prototypical as I like to say and I
don't actually have a crazy conservative
uncle but I've got some lefty conspiracy
theorists in my family and that can be
just as challenging I guess at holiday
events